Hey, Michael.
Good morning.
Good morning, Naira. How are ya?
I'm doing great. I'm pretty excited for the coming weekend. Yeah. How about you?
Nice.
Happy birthday to you!
Thank you so much.
I'm pretty excited too. I'm traveling tomorrow morning, really early actually. Flight leaves around like 5 something in the morning. So it's going to be pretty early, but you know, it's going to be fun. You're going with, you're going with friends and family.
Yeah, it's gonna be fine, yeah.
Yeah, family.
Nice, nice, nice.
Okay, that's good that we have already plans. I'm looking forward for this because I normally take like a week off every birthday, every birth month. So I do this yearly. I usually take five days off.
PH.
Mhm.
Nice.
And do you usually go to the same place, to the same beach, or do you go somewhere else?
No.
No, somewhere else. I like to explore. I like to explore new places, yeah. And then...
Oh, okay.
Nice.
Have you been to where you're going tomorrow or is that a new place for you?
Not yet, this is the first time, first time.
Oh, cool. Cool. That's awesome.
Yeah, I normally get bored when I went to a place and then, yeah, I want to explore places I have never been to. That's my kind of thing.
Yeah.
Nice. That's awesome.
Yeah, okay. Shall we start, Michael?
Yeah, of course.
Let me just quickly check in with Andrea if she's going to join. Give me a few seconds.
No problem, we're, I guess, a minute early.
Okay, cool. I sent her a message. So while we're waiting, I'm going to quickly share my screen here. Let me know once it is visible, Marco.
There you go. Can you see me?
That's coming up.
Okay.
Okay, yeah, now I can.
All right. So once again, thank you, Marco, for joining our bi-weekly service call. Today we're going to be reviewing the performance of Jane from April 27th to May 8th. So this is actually our week #9, so that's pretty fast, if I can say.
Mhm.
Moving on to the agenda items, that's all the same. Check in and updates, highlights, performance analysis, and open Q&A.
For check-in, this is for you, Marco. How are things at this moment with you and Jane? Are there anything you want to discuss?
OK.
Up.
No, I mean, things so far are going okay.
No challenges faced for the past few weeks.
No, not really. I mean, in reality, I guess it's what it is, right? I mean, she's still new, she's still going through the learning process, but she's doing well. She's asking questions. She, you know, she knows, you know, what to do. And if, you know, she has made a mistake, she fixes it. So, I mean,
all within what you expect to see during, you know, the first, you know, pretty much month of somebody running independently and also, you know, of any new employee. So, so far, I think things are okay.
Good to hear. So far, so good. I can see Natalie joined. Hey, Natalie, how are you?
Oh, hey, Natalie.
Hey, how are you both doing?
Good, and you?
Doing well, doing well. Now, halfway through the week, always good.
Yeah, awesome.
Okay, perfect. I'm going to move on to the next slide, which is the highlights. I have two for you. For the past few weeks, we maintained consistent service quality across all work streams. So I haven't received any escalations or critical incidents from you, so that's a good thing. And second,
part, we've maintained uninterrupted coverage, so we made sure that there were no service gaps for the entire two weeks. That's good. For the performance analysis, we have this IT by design recommended KPIs. This is specifically for Jane for dispatch.
Yeah.
You already know all of these KPIs, Marco, so if you wanted to discuss anything from here, just let me know so we can discuss it further. Plus, moving on to the, what's happening here? There. So I haven't prepared any
graph or data yet for you. I am still trying to figure out how I'm going to get all of this KPIs. I'm planning to do my board reviews with Jane. That way I would be able to log into her Connectwise Manage or just to see it.
so I can get the report. But then let me ask you, because the last time we spoke about my daily standup, you mentioned that we need to make sure that there's no interruptions that would happen for 15 minutes. So I would like to request if I can take
30 minutes of her time weekly so I could do this board reviews with her. Would you think that one day around 3.30 to 4 I can do the board reviews?
You're on mute, sorry.
Sorry, pulling an idiot in here. So yes, towards the end of the day, in the afternoon, I would say tends to be the better of times because that's usually when we have the least calls and maybe the less chances that we will be needing a CSR to.
Is OK.
triage something, you know, very urgently. So I think we should be okay. So I think, you know, 30 minutes a week, that's completely fine.
Okay, perfect. That would help me get all of these things right here so I could prep her scorecard. Also, I can see Andrea joined. Hi, good morning. Thank you for joining.
Hi, Marco. Sorry I'm late. How are you?
Hey, Andrea, how are you?
Doing alright, doing alright.
How is your vacation so far?
Well, I start vacation tomorrow, so tomorrow I will be perfect.
That's fun.
Where are you going?
Yep.
Nicole, please. No.
Now, I can tell you in terms of, so I have given you numbers before, but just so you have an idea, it's just the past two weeks. So she triaged, so that doesn't mean that she was the one that took the call necessarily, but that means that she triaged the ticket. It could be the
Mhm.
You know, there was an update that needed to happen to an assistant ticket that already was triaged, so it could have been someone calling for an update or emailing for an update or things like that. So past two weeks, because I gave you numbers before, for the past two weeks, he handled 182 tickets.
All right. In terms of things that usually go into our in-house board, which is most of the tickets go into our in-house board, there is another thing that the managers of that area of those techs, they do a lot of like what we call teach back. So
If we see mistakes or something like that, then we get back to, what they do is they get back to the CSR, including myself, about, hey, you know, this is what happened. So only in the past two weeks, she only had one teach back. And in reality, for being a new employee, I think that's.
Pretty sweet, pretty good. And really at the end of the day, I even talked to, you know, within that chat, even to the manager of that area saying, you know, there's a lot of variables into what you're saying. So for us to get a consistent thing is kind of difficult, but.
Jane was like, yeah, no, I got it. I understand. And it was good. So I mean, overall, I think the experience so far with Jane has been very positive. She's acclimating with the team well. She's participating in our level 10s. So I think I see her getting along with other people.
So I think overall we're in a good space right now.
That's great to hear. Really great to hear. I feel like, and every time that I see Jane, I think she's very self-sufficient. She is asking questions, especially reach out. She's reaching out also to Ayra locally if she has anything. So I think that's a very, very good sign for her so far. So good to hear that.
Okay.
Go ahead, Ayra.
And.
Okay, thank you. So that's that for the ITBD by Design KPI. So as mentioned to Marco a while ago, I haven't prepared any data for her performance yet because I'm still trying to get the report from her end. But then
Since we settled the 30 minutes per week, so that's going to be Monday, 330 to 4, I'm going to be reviewing her boards, her connect wise Spanish. That way I could present a report. Maybe this coming.
Um, for I would say I'll do that by June so that I could prepare all the data perfectly. Would that be fine with you, Marco?
Yeah, that's completely fine. That's not a problem at all.
Okay, okay, cool. And for the ITBD design services that we offer, these are all the things, these are all the products that we have. So if you need anything from this, you can reach out to us.
Okay.
And yeah, for Build It Live, we have this event. Could you tell me, could you help me out on this, Natalie, if you have information?
You know, I think Natalie doesn't even need the help. Natalie knows I'm already registered for this. So I register every year. Now, Natalie, for what, for the past maybe four years or so that you convinced me the first time?
Your training Okay.
Yeah, you're our biggest fan.
Wow.
So the only thing I'm waiting now is for the agenda so I can figure out what I can do on that someday.
That's great to hear.
Yeah.
Yeah, you should be getting an email. The hotel blocks are open, so you should be getting an email about the hotel blocks at least.
Hi, Javid. Do we have?
Thank you.
Oh, the hotel block has been open for a long time. I already registered.
Okay, well, that's that was the news.
It's just that an email never went out; it was in it was on the website.
Okay, gotcha, gotcha.
The.
Well, but yeah, agenda still, they keep saying it should be out, so hopefully we'll get an email soon about the agenda.
And, and just quick question: were you able to switch out Scott and and and put Jeremy in place?
They were, Nikki was supposed to reach out and finalize everything, so I'll just double check that she has all the right registrants.
Okay, yeah, if anything, just have her contact me, please.
Okay.
Okay, cool. We're settled on this part. Let's move on to the way forward. I've checked your calendar, Marco, and you're going to be out. Your office will be closed on May 25th, right? Okay. I'll have that settled on our end as well. And the last part.
Correct.
Yeah, we continue to provide you with the reliable coverage that you need for your daily operations. And please know that if you need any help with your operations, if you need people, we're here for you. We can help you out, okay?
OK, appreciate it.
And that's the end of my slide. Do you have any questions for us, Michael?
Not a question, just a quick comment so you guys are aware.
So we have performance reviews that happen every May. So we have one, we have quarterly reviews, but outside of that, we have performance, yearly performance reviews that happen every May. So.
I will be conducting a performance review with her anyways, even though technically she has only been with us maybe for all two months. You know, usually someone gets a formal review at 90 days, but she will go through that process. There will, of course, there won't be anything in terms of like...
races or things like that, but it's just to at least, you know, she has in writing how she's doing, where she's at, her numbers, all that stuff, right? So just be aware, we go through that process, she's going to go through that process of like her performance review, even though it technically has not really been a year.
Okay, are you doing it in Team GPS?
No, we are not doing that on Team GPS, no.
Okay. All right. So do you need any help from our end?
Nope, I don't need anything from your end. I have all the stuff that I need. So I'm just waiting at this point. It's not even from any of you guys. I'm just waiting for Miranda to give me information in terms of
On this just change, OK.
Okay.
my team so I can finally schedule those performance review. Actually, the only thing that I would need from you guys, if you have that, is a punctuality attendance list. Yeah. So if you have that, that would be great. I mean, I haven't.
Attendance.
seen you guys or message. I've not seen any messages from you saying that she's going to be late or anything like that. So I'm assuming that she's arriving on time every time, but you know, but if you guys have that formally, then if you send me that, that's good. But again.
I.
Yes.
Mhm.
That's about it in terms of what I may need from you for that.
Cool, I can send you the report. When would you need it?
Okay.
That.
When would you need it? You need it next week? Coming? Next week is fine. Okay, I'll check our...
Yeah, next week is fine. Next week is fine. Yeah.
Times time time entry system, and I'll give you the report that you need. So, apart from that, is there anything else?
No.
Okay, cool. Natalie, do you have anything for us?
No, I'm all good.
Okay, and lastly, Andrea, anything you want to discuss here?
Nope, not really. I appreciate you registering to build it. So happy to see you there soon.
We're good.
Oh, cool. You're going to be there? That's awesome.
Like.
Yeah, should be there. Thank you. Hey there. Thanks, Marco. Appreciate your help with the Jane. And soon, once we have that three month data, we'll be able to show you how she performs on the numbers. Okay.
Nice.
At.
Okay, well, thank you. I appreciate it. And well, looking forward to seeing all of you guys that build it or whoever is going to make it.
See ya.
At.
Sure. Bye.
All right, bye.
Thank you guys for joining service call. Goodbye.